who are there,
who show real courage, who bring people together,
and to nudge our sons to identify with those heroines
and to say, "I want to be on their team,"
because they're going to be on their team.
When I asked my daughter who her favorite character was in "Star Wars,"
do you know what she said?
Obi-Wan.
Obi-Wan Kenobi and Glinda.
What do these two have in common?
Maybe it's not just the sparkly dress.
I think these people are experts.
I think these are the two people in the movie
who know more than anybody else,
and they love sharing their knowledge with other people
to help them reach their potential.
Now, they are leaders.
I like that kind of quest for my daughter,
and I like that kind of quest for my son.
I want more quests like that.
I want fewer quests where my son is told,
"Go out and fight it alone,"
and more quests where he sees that it's his job to join a team,
maybe a team led by women,
to help other people become better
and be better people,
like the Wizard of Oz.
Thank you.